hello it's very nice to be here and an
honor as school is winding down here at
Yale I just have a few informal remarks
and I just thought I would start by
saying that one of the really great
things about being an architecture
writer is you are always on duty and
there's nowhere you go where you are not
an architectural tourist I'm not going
to I'm going to just show you a couple
of buildings I saw on a recent trip to
Israel that was not even a reporting
trip but sort of turned into one because
this is a building that some of you were
interested in architecture and all of
you who are interested in journalism may
see a lot of in a few months it's an
addition to the Televi museum of art is
anybody here been to Tel Aviv so it's a
really wonderful architecture city more
Bauhaus buildings than anywhere else in
the world this was designed by Preston
Scott Cohen who's the chair of
architecture at the Graduate School of
Design at that University up in
cambridge massachusetts i forget the
name of it you know that big one
university of the north yeah and what's
interesting about this building is that
it looks like one of those kind of
faceted spectacle buildings that we've
seen a lot of in the last 10 or 15 years
particularly for cultural institutions
and it looks as if the inside is going
to also have all of these kind of wild
angles and in fact what he is done when
you get inside it there's this
incredible central core that the museum
goes way into the several stories below
grade all lit from with daylight and is
kind of like a inside were tornado all
these different angles and curves and
off of these spin perfectly orthogonal
galleries so it's kind of the best or
worst if you like it it's a kind of he's
got it both ways he's got a really
interesting sort of spectacle museum
that is sitting in the middle of his
plaza with this incredible circulation
area but the actual galleries
is calm and easy for the curators to use
and install as a classic modernist box
and then I wanted to go see this museum
I don't know if you've seen pictures of
it it's in a suburb south of Tel Aviv
called holon it was it's a design museum
designed by ron arad it's london-based
is really born designer and it's kind of
it's kind of amazing looking as you
approach it but it turns out that it's
all packaging this is just these corten
steel ribbons our trap a completely
ordinary concrete box to level museum
but it does make some beautiful spaces
of on the exterior for a courtyard and a
cafe and so forth and then in Jerusalem
I went to the newly revamped Israel
Museum just a wonderful Museum that I
was very pleased to see in general and
it has just been reordered and
reorganized by a New York designer James
Carpenter who put these beautiful glass
pavilions very quiet very serene in
front of the museum but it's a kind of
campus museum and they renovated the
original building by an architect named
Alfred man's felled it was built in the
1960s and it's fantastically interesting
architecture with galleries that are
clear story windows round with beautiful
light poured concrete and each galleries
that have held up by this kind of tulip
shaped column in the center it's quite
dramatic so it was this interesting to
see the original architecture restored
as the additional architecture and new
circulation contributed by Jamie
carpenter now on the campus of this
museum in the garden which was designed
by noguchi by the way is this really
wacky looking building called the shore
called the shrine of the book it was
designed by Frederick he flirts some
people say it's the only building he
designed I think he designed one other
building but he's primarily a kind of a
teacher writer set designer live
New York born in Vienna and it was
designed in the middle 60s to hold the
Dead Sea Scrolls which are extraordinary
and the Dead Sea Scrolls got me to
thinking they're so beautiful and you
think of their hundreds of them and you
think about all of the human effort of
these scribes sitting there writing
putting down these words and a 2,000
years ago and all of the scribes and
monks and so forth who wrote down the
written word until we got to Gutenberg
and now here we are in the 21st century
and Gutenberg and the printing press
movable type is now obsolete and now we
have instead this guy and what he's
holding is something that I hope will
talk about in the panel because some
people think it's the end of magazines
as we know it and I think it is the
opposite okay I want to talk a little
bit about when I went to Newsweek I'm
showing this cover because this is a
cover from large 23rd 1970 before I went
there but in in the 70s and 80s a
Newsweek and Time magazine were very
much part of what we might call the
national conversation very aggressively
reporting on politics and world affairs
and trends so this was the magazine they
produced as i said in early nineteen
seventy to write about the growing
feminist movement what the male editors
and writers who put this cover together
could not have possibly known was in the
very week that this hit the newsstands
46 editorial women at Newsweek who are
all in positions of researcher with
their high high education and experience
filed a federal employment
discrimination suit against the magazine
this magazine also was owned by a woman
Katharine Graham on the washington post
company probably the most powerful woman
in publishing at that time
sites maybe Dorothy ship and ultimately
the suit was settled and when I got to
the magazine about seven or eight years
later I was the beneficiary of a lot of
the provisions of that suit of course I
still had to start as a researcher that
was the entry level position I was I had
been a art history English double major
in college I was assigned to the art
critic and things were still not perfect
at the magazine there were in the in the
culture departments there were eight
critics only one of them was a woman and
she was the third string book reviewer
who always got the last choice of what
books to review and there were six
researchers on five of us were women
there was only one guy but there was the
ability to move ahead what my first
tasks were doing reporting the very
first interview I was ever sent on was
to interview this gentleman the art
critic was writing a cover story about
Jasper Johns and andy warhol and Jasper
Johns have been really good friends when
they were unknown young artists in New
York and the 50s and so I went to the
factory to interview Warhol and my tape
recorder didn't work and I had not had
nothing but a kind of this almond a
sickening faint buzz when I went to
listen to it the interview but it
actually didn't really matter i had my
notebook and Andy Warhol was so
basically ticked that the story wasn't
about him that he answered every
question I asked him in a monosyllable
everything was in my notes was kind of
great or g so i began to occasionally be
lamp to the architecture critic to do
reporting for him and i really enjoyed
that first of all architects really knew
how to sell sell themselves sell their
ideas they were way better talkers and
artists and I gradually began to learn
that field I was fairly soon promoted to
writer I had to write
I was kind of lowly culture writer means
which meant I was writing about a lot of
low culture but ultimately there was an
opening the architecture beat had been
kind of abandoned and i asked the editor
if i could i began to suggest stories
and revive the beat now i'm showing you
this picture a very familiar picture
because in the last 15 or 20 years since
i've been working in this field there
were two events really which made me
realize how much the audience for
architecture and design has changed
grown and become more sophisticated and
of course the reaction to this building
certainly by a lot of people haven't
even seen it who didn't even travel to
bilbao and the reaction to Frank Gehry
was kind of phenomenal I think in the in
the field of architecture and you know
people are always saying you know he was
mentioned on The Simpsons he was
mentioned on Law & Order sudden you know
that the museum appeared and you know a
zillion movies James Bond movies anyway
it just became a kind of icon of popular
culture and really impacted architecture
i think in both good ways and bad which
we can also talk about in the panel it's
certainly unleashed a spate of wannabes
and museums who wanted a big-name
architecture design their museum or the
addition to their museum and if the
architect wasn't a big name yet they
were going to make him a big name and we
got all very caught up in the celebrity
culture of architecture the other event
which is very very different which
actually also showed how involved people
were in the idea of design was of course
this one and as horrific as the event
was on 911 and we're coming up to the
10th anniversary what was really
heartening about being in New York at
that time was the outpouring a public
response about what should happen to
this site I have a hard time looking
that picture so I'm going to go to the
next one and this outpouring a public
response
there were sure s there were meetings
there were forums there were places
where ordinary people could go and with
the help of various facilitators they
could gather in groups with architects
trace paper and draw what they thought
should happen thousands literally
thousands i think maybe even tens of
thousands of designs maybe that's an
exaggeration but between ten and twenty
thousand designs for what should happen
at Ground Zero were sent to people in
New York I got some in the mail too I
mean they were just sent to everybody I
took them to an organization called the
Municipal Art Society which was running
a lot of these programs and ultimately
when the public body charged with
rebuilding Ground Zero produced six
schemes all by an architectural firm
called Beyer blinder Belle they were
just lamb basted by the public at a big
meeting held at the Javits Convention
Center and the point about all of this
is that people responded passionately to
the idea of urban design and
architecture so in response to the
public's displeasure with the original
plans competition was held six teams
submitted had six weeks to come up with
the master plan which is actually kind
of ridiculous and at the end of the six
weeks and a lot more public discussion
editorials that is the editor etc Daniel
Lee the skin one if you call this
winning and of course what's happened
has been kind of disappointing however
you feel about this particular scheme
there was a lot of I think the public
and a lot of the coverage wasn't really
very realistic about how planning works
and also how New York Palace to politics
and real estate work and there was one
critic who foretold it all and I'm going
to just read you a little bit that was
published shortly after the Twin Towers
collapsed that fall of two thousand one
one can almost
object what New York but the New York
process will be the city can show its
compassion and its resolve but it is
also a city incapable of the large
appropriate gesture in the public
interest if it costs too much if the
usual scenario is followed the debate
will lead to a solution in which
principle is lost in an epic opportunity
squandered with the best intentions the
Municipal Art Society a conscientious
watchdog of the city's urban quality
will announce a competition to determine
what should be done with the site the
results will make a nice little
exhibition and discussions and lectures
will be held all this will be ignored by
the movers and shakers guess anybody ada
louise huxtable was kind of the goddess
of this field certainly I'm not alone
and being a critic who Revere's her
above almost anyone else and fortunately
at 89 she is still writing though not as
frequently as we might like in The Wall
Street Journal as sharply as ever for a
long time at least a decade before nine
eleven I had begun writing not only
about certain buildings when they open
but I really have began to develop an
interest in cities and did numerous
projects for Newsweek on cities that
were an interesting moment or
interesting flux Barcelona before the
Olympics Berlin when it was going to
become the capital of a united Germany
and Havana a city I very much worried
about because it has in addition to the
colonial architecture which is quite
well-known fantastically interesting
modern architecture and the city is so
untouched relatively crumbling but
untouched and I worry about what will
happen when Castro dies and the real
estate developers of the world descend I
think that writing about cities I think
writing about I think the architectural
profession in itself especially among
the younger generation is
collaborating much more many firms
there's a lot there are a lot of
projects which blur the line between
urban design landscape art architecture
and I think that same vein I think
critics going forward need to look at
the world more broadly than individual
buildings and certainly with half the
world living in cities and cities that
are sort of being developed or helter
skelter and with their own kind of
internal logic and reason or lack of
logic it's a very important thing to
study and to bring to the press this is
just kind of a remarkable image that
sort of speaks for itself this is South
Paulo Brazil and this is not a
photoshopped picture of side by side
living in all those little terraces on
the right half swimming pools next to
the favela I want to talk a little bit
about writing in the mainstream I'll
just say and we'll come on this more in
the panel that you know it's really not
at all like writing for the choir it's
not writing further architects it's not
writing for other critics it's certainly
not scholarly certainly having a
position and persuading and trying to
affect the public good is something that
I think all of us want to do sometimes
it's on a very small scale you just want
readers to be more aware of the world
around them and to have some sense of
the criteria the backstory the politics
the finances that go into creating the
built environment certainly I think when
I first started writing about
architecture we were very focused on
trends we were very focused on you know
what was going to come after
post-modernism what was
to come after a deconstruction I mean we
thought it was going to all people you
know our editors wanted to know was it
all going to logically unfold the way we
sort of see art history is unfolding
that I think we've gotten quite beyond
that I think we're living in a very
pluralistic design climate and I think
that's all for the good I'm also will
just end by saying I am interested in
the past particularly the recent past
I'm very interested in modernism as
Carter mentioned i'm at work researching
a book on a lien starin and arrows
Darren and second wife who was quite an
extraordinary woman in her own right not
very well known now who was a
award-winning critic for the New York
Times the 1940s a best-selling author in
the 1950s and then after sarren ends
death kind of reinvented herself is a
television news journalist and a pioneer
in that field to kind of arrival with
Barbara Walters she was the first
Network foreign bureau chief she also
was incredibly important to Sarah nuns
career in ways that the catalog and
exhibition that was here at Yale last
spring touched on she was fantastic at
promoting him in their marriage in the
50s to her to the press in general and a
lot of powerful people she knew but
after his death she became particularly
vigilant about his legacy I called her
the Yoko Ono of architecture because she
really controlled what as best she could
what was written about him she had an
office in the office what is now the
Kevin Roche office that was the sarin an
office in hamden and she because so many
of his pre died very suddenly and so
many of his prod major projects were not
finished she was very instrumental in
smoothing things over with the clients
and assuring them that arrow had
designed at
thing down to the doorknobs they would
be built as exactly as he had presented
them that the people in the office could
handle this she was tremendously
important to him and I will just end
this and then we'll get on to our chat
by something else that you should all be
aware of this is eros Aaron ins house
for J orwin Miller probably one of the
if not the most important patrons of
modern architecture in America in the
post-war period a Yalie a fellow of the
Yale Corporation Commission this house
in the middle 50 who is a very close
friend of Sarah nuns and it's been in
the family until only the last year or
so and is now it was given to the
indianapolis museum of art it's in
columbus indiana which if you haven't
been you must go it's fantastic place
and this house is opening to the public
for the first time in may i had the
privilege of going through it last
summer and it's really beautiful with an
interior by alexander girard the end of
incredible landscape by Dan Kiley a real
collaboration among three giants of
design frequently work together so on
that note I will prepare to bat off the
questions that Carter and Paul are going
to hurl at me thank you I just but I
don't know how to trim this off it's
really with that do you want to trim can
you just turn it off just kill it thank
you
jinjja lights whoops I'm sorry well that
was fascinating and did exactly what I
think we were hoping for which is to
span a spectrum of experienced and
professional involvement that the title
of the of the visit is included
journalism and architecture and
criticism and we want to touch on all
those things and it's wonderful having
poll here representing the undergraduate
journalism world and then I see in the
audience quite a number of our own
students in the graduate school and I
thought maybe we could just go back to
open this up to some remarks that
Kathleen made at the beginning about her
her entry into the the world of
journalism it's it's hard to imagine now
just how bad things were only only a few
years ago when journalism was dominated
by men white men who had very little
interest in the women in the profession
certainly as professionals and maybe you
could you could talk a little bit about
what what it was like being at a
magazine that forced its women employees
to sue the magazine in order to become
journalists well as I said I was I was
not there then but a lot of the women
were still there who had brought this
suit and what one of them had become an
editor a senior editor among six senior
editors and there were a couple of
reporters in euros but it was still as I
described in my own Department things
were still fairly uneven and you know
you kind of had to work and make your
way in a way this hope that well I'll
give you one example
the one of the things we had to do as
researchers besides report do a lot of
reporting was we had to fact check the
stories of the writers and if you made a
mistake I never made mistake but if you
made a mistake and I'll somebody wrote a
letter to the editor the letter came to
you and you got it was it was called a
Barbie to remember those it was named
after a woman who was head of research
for about 50 years and if you had to
document your you that either had to
confess the error document your the
proof of the fact and there was getting
a lot of Barbies could get you fired
well the sort of class and I entered
with the fall I came there were now some
male researchers they had two stars
researchers of this one guy got so many
Barbies he was such a terrible
fact-checker that he was promoted to
correspondent in Los Angeles Bureau and
then became a movie producer whereas
those of us who were absolutely great at
it you know women were so
detail-oriented you know it got kind of
stuck it was a atmosphere and of course
one took it for granted because there
was there was nothing else around and
then things did begun Indian begin to
change but also slowly now of course
things are were dramatically different
and we're we're happy about that maybe
you could you could move us along a
little bit Kathleen by talking about how
you not only rose up at that magazine
but how you got into the area of
covering architecture and design if I
remember right one of the great
distinctions of Newsweek it in
competition with time was that it took
on some very bold issues the the women
in revolt was one but culture in America
I think was another major one woman all
under the editorship of someone in gauze
born Elliott and the situation in the
United States in in the cities was
in crisis proportions and there were
riots and fires and horrible things
going on so there was there was an added
focus on this but I never knew quite how
how Newsweek moved from that into the
coverage of high design well that was
also a little before my time the kind of
burning cities but that was certainly
covered as a national news story by not
by cultural reporters you know
architectural criticism was always a bit
of a poor stepchild in the culture
section and it was was a poor stepchild
to the art critics actually and it in a
Time magazine in fact the art critic was
the Robert Hughes was really wrote the
architecture pieces and they were fairly
rare even at Newsweek I felt I really
had to fight for space and it gradually
became easier i would say maybe in the
1990s and i don't just count something
like bilbao that suddenly that was
considered news and it was a news
magazine and so you had to persuade your
editors of the importance culturally of
a particular venter and opening of a
building or something like that it what
was more difficult was to persuade them
of some kind of trend idea that you had
that might be unique that they could not
necessarily you know read about in the
New York Times New York Times wasn't
unfortunately a great indicator to
editors that something had to be covered
or that something had already been
missed had that experience a few times
on Bilbao you were pretty early to the
story and one of the first people to
write about the building before he was
finished so what true there and how did
you have a sense did you have a sense of
what it would be and kind of the
importance that the building would come
to have well it was news and I did write
the first national story about Bilbao
and I kind of got in trouble for it
actually but it was already huge news
every artist in America who could get
there was getting their people
were talking about it Phillip Johnson
who was the architect who was the great
promoter of all things architectural had
gone on the charlie rose show about a
year before it open and said that it was
going to be the greatest building of the
second half of the 20th century and so
everybody knew it was happening and
people barely could find Bilbao Spain on
a map but they knew it was going to be
big so because I worked for a news
magazine and because it was so difficult
and competitive and did I just worked
and worked and worked until I got uh
persuaded the Guggenheim people and Gary
that they should let me come and do a
story I see the building under
construction it was mostly finished but
the interior was far from finished and
interview him there and I did that and I
wrote a story that very clearly said the
building was not finished and of course
I didn't see it with the art installed
and there was all kinds of scaffolding
still inside but the outside was mostly
complete and it was extremely dramatic
and colleague of mine who I like very
much I've gotta know since then Blair
kaman of such Chicago Tribune wrote a
piece that attacked me for reviewing the
building before it was open I think you
mischaracterize my piece is a review but
I think what he said was important in
that I think everybody got so it was so
competitive to get two stories first and
I often had the experience if something
already been covered my editors would
say was too late and it's it's not a
very healthy atmosphere and it's
certainly one that's getting worse now
in the 24 7 news cycle with the internet
I mean something is old the day after it
opens what I think is unfortunate in
terms of architectural criticism is that
it's very hard to persuade an editor in
a mainstream magazine to let you revisit
a building months after its open and see
how it really works does it really
to its billing do how do people move
through it how is the light all times of
day how is the you know what is it like
in different seasons and and that's
something where I think we as critics
kind of fail though it's not entirely
our fault because I wanted to ask just
question about I think the raised here
Kathleen because unlike the coverage of
the other arts covering architecture
requires doing well doing it in the
depth that you're just describing
requires access to the people who made
it they architect the clients the
financial people and so forth and
there's a quid pro quo there I certainly
went through some of this myself but I'd
be curious to know what your some of
your experiences if the architect
doesn't like you he or she is not going
to give you access to that information
and if he or she does then you were
likely to get first shot at it and this
puts the writer in a rather awkward
position mm-hmm so do you have any war
stories on that um teens turn gives
access to everyone I think one of the
issues I think you're right i think it
is different from other art forms and
it's not strictly an art form but one of
the things that kind of bugs me is that
certainly film reviewers and book
reviewers do not you know hang out with
the author of the book or the i'm not
even sure they don't ever hang out with
filmmakers or authors and other events
but it's not part of the job you go to
the movie you read the book you read the
author's other books you write your
piece it's almost impossible it's not
it's not impossible but it's much more
common to spend time talking to an
architect or his office about intentions
materials engineering the client and so
forth what bothers me
is the conceit perhaps it um the
nation's best-known newspaper that the
critic has not talked to the architect
because at the New York Times there's
this kind of wall between the critics
and the reporters I once when I was arts
editor I tried to hire a terrific writer
at the time so was writing about design
and in the lobby and it's very hard to
lure people from the times because it is
new york times you said could I write
criticism I said yeah you know we do a
kind of cultural reporting you can do a
straight review or we do pieces that are
reported where you can express your
opinion um and she said because at the
time she could not write criticism it
was completely separate well we know
that the architecture critics there need
the same kind of information that the
critic 'it time or Newsweek needs to
adequately do their piece so it's it's
it seems to me that the best method is
just to be very upfront about it which I
tend to do by writing cultural pieces
what I call called architectural
reporting pieces in which i quote
whoever I've spoken to we talked about
the legacy of Bilbao and I think
certainly one is the focus on celebrity
architects in their work do you think
that worked by lesser-known architects
is ignored and sort of how can
architectural journals go about and
getting their editors to let them write
about maybe things that are by someone
nobody's ever heard of um I like to
think that in the new age of digital
journalism where there's so many more
outlets that's going to be more possible
I think when you get very intrigued with
a lesser-known architect what I've tried
to do is I've tried to see what's going
on in the profession
in a in a broader way to see if I can
piece together some ideas that are
reflected in the work of a young
architect or group of young architects
and I find that I have been able to
persuade my editors that there is
something happening out there that the
readers need to be aware of and it's a
little easier to do not to lump people
together you can certainly talk about
them individually but to describe it as
an aspect of what's going on in
architectural culture but more and more
I think lesser-known architects are
getting some kind of attention through
the internet don't you think so yeah and
there's a on your earlier point there's
actually a blog now that revisits a lot
of famous buildings five years after
they opened and looks at what condition
they're in and kind of how they're
holding up that's what's a called don't
know okay we'll find it we'll put
Kathleen making that sort of choice
early on picking talent talent spotting
early on requires a sharp eye and a
defensible set of standards i would say
criteria and I'd just be interested to
know how you what the tools are you use
to pass a judgment on a building that
may be unfamiliar and is not yet
certified if you like mm-hmm well it's a
really good question I knew you were
gonna ask it and now i'm going to just
ask it half of these people have already
been through the exercise obviously i
can't call it a gut feeling but you know
having looked at a lot of buildings over
a lot of years and been learned as much
as i possibly can i think you know the
first there are just a number of
criteria that you look at you no one is
sort of the authenticity of the idea i
mean i think one of the most depressing
things that followed the Bilbao
enthusiasm was a lot of poor imitation
and I think that got a little I think
that's very unfortunate and you can kind
of tell and this is we're actually
talking to architects I find very
helpful because you really wanted you
you give somebody a chance to defend
their work and find out if they really
have an idea if there's really some
meaning in there if it's really um can
we swear at you should be yes I'll just
go further can I actually um so there's
something in that but you know then
you're looking at a lot of the things
that we're all looking at with witches
you know hat how do you feel in the
space you look at the details how well
is it crafted what are the materials and
why were they chosen what's the light
like I mean it's it can be pretty
fundamental and if it's if it's
something that's you know highly unusual
like this Scott Cohen building and Tel
Aviv you really want to ask yourself
well why why did he make it look like a
meteorite had landed in the middle of
that plaza right bob is not and that's
what Bob that wanna meet so that becomes
part of the you know the criteria as
well I quite liked it on the inside i
will say much more than the outside if
that's what you're getting at and but
what he did that I thought is you know
deserves credit and description is
because it was a very tight site and
it's triangular site and he always had
the idea of apparently of doing these
you know orthogonal rectilinear
galleries these kind of classic
galleries that when they be hand to work
out the geometry on the computer that's
when they sort of created this kind of
you know inside a tornado kind of atrium
how much that relates to the facets on
the outside I can't tell you because I
haven't really studied it yet but I I'm
going to one of the things that's come
up in our course and Paul has been
involved in this is
someone and always ask me if there were
any regrets that I had any mistakes
looking back and I rapidly confess a few
did you make any mistakes never um you
know I think it's back to actually this
kind of little theme and then I'm going
to ask you yours too i'm not going to
sit up here and just admit when we were
the authority tonight um i think uh
obviously because it's a national news
magazine i wrote a lot about public
buildings particularly cultural
buildings and i do think that in that
frenzy to be first there were certainly
some projects you know which do not work
well for their function as they should
and that obviously matters and when you
see them you know gleaming and seemingly
so original and fresh you know and we
have a couple of very important critics
among us who you know always review the
same five people because they want to
see architecture advance so listen I
like advancing as much as the next
person but when advancing doesn't work
when you go back and revisit it six
months later you kind of go well I sort
of hinted at that but I wish had been a
little harsher okay i'm curious about
sarin and since you're writing the book
about his wife how important was the
media to his work and how good we know
his wife was very good at working with
reporters and critics but how good it
was sarin himself well I think you I
think he was good very good at it and I
don't want to take anything away from
his work by saying that he was hyped but
I do think it's important to realize I
mean what this one of the things that
makes it so interesting when there's a
show like the show that was Yale and
when you go back and look you know sarin
and was almost completely forgotten for
20 or 30 years he was barely in some of
the you know main compendiums of 20th
century architecture and he's really
been rediscovered and re appreciated
I think he wasn't a better known for his
furniture for a long time um but to go
back and look at this period in the
early to mid 1950s you realize that he
used was really every bit as big as
Frank Gehry became and Bilbao he was on
the cover of Time magazine which was you
know huge deal then he did this project
at warren michigan the General Motors
Technical Center which was the biggest
single architectural Commission in
America was a hundred and in the world
actually I think one hundred million
dollars of multiple buildings
fascinating thing about it is that it's
very hard to get into I've driven by it
and I'm I'm actually working on how I'm
going to get in there it's kind of like
Fort Knox nothi it's because they still
design cars there and so it's you know
they're designing for the future they
don't want anybody to see it but what I
thought was so interesting about the way
it was displayed and the sarin and show
was they had vintage pictures the cars
the gold and the building stone cold
they still look fantastic so he was
hugely important and appreciated in his
era and it wasn't just promotion but
what she did which I think was a little
unusual was through her context they
were not just on the cover of time or in
all the architecture magazines but you
know at home with a lean and arrow and
Vogue magazine Harper's Bazaar you know
the kind of magazines we see now that do
sort of architects as celebrities ah he
was really one of the first of those
well I was wondering at what point we
wanted to open it up we prepped some of
the folks to ask him site for questions
and we're looking for is a naughty truck
we've tried to plant as many as possible
do you have some other things for
chemical rudder or we have we all right
she's been desperate to get rid of this
water
my own well what what what do we what
can Kathleen or Eduardo you thank you
thank you so much it's been very helpful
and actually I run out of good questions
because I think your fans are almost all
of them but I since we reached this
point maybe we could get into more
detail I was curious about how would be
the process of starting to think of
writing about something whether you will
persuade someone and you get persuaded
and then how would you go about it you
mention about meeting with a client and
the architect but I'm curious about
whether you will have always access to
go to these places a what kind of
material will you be looking at
photographs plans hey how do you relate
to to this material and how also do you
go about selecting photographs for the
publication and what role do you think
photographs happen to these articles
maybe maybe an addendum to that is is it
still necessary you know today with all
the technology and all the photographs
available to actually travel to the site
oh my god I'm shot shot I want on Google
you haven't graduated yet you're killing
me I once wrote a piece actually for the
what was then the sort of embryonic
Newsweek website about the r you alive
before the internet oh that's a sweet
about how photography famous
architectural photographer degraff
completely misled you about the
experience and two of the most famous
ones I cited is the that case that case
study house the chronic case cut study
has words that sort of a corner of a
glass house it's leaning over the los
angeles basin with all of the lights
below you know there isn't a person you
could show the front door of that house
to who would record
is it the second one is one of my
favorite sort of idiotic ones was the
most famous picture of a REM koolhaas
building when he was first getting
famous was of a house he did outside
Paris and has a woman diving about to
dive in a pool and the Eiffel Towers in
the distance and it's at night could
anybody describe the house this little
teeny house with the you know the post
going every which way it doesn't mean it
doesn't it's not remotely glamorous like
that picture I'm told that he hates the
picture but you know he got quite a ride
with it so I'm not sure that in any case
you know I think architectural
photography is useful but extreme can be
extremely misleading a very dear friend
of mine who's a wonderful Arctic point
said to me the first time I went to the
Glass House so small you know you just
there's no way to get that philip
johnson's class house New Canaan
Connecticut there's no way to get scale
unless you put people in the pictures
architects hate to have people in the
pictures photography is very important
I'm going to the site is essential
they're never going to invent something
that is going to make Google Earth okay
however I think the potential of the
internet and it's we could talk about
the ipad for a minute for covering
architecture and bring the reader to the
experience is fantastic because virtual
tours and so many more photographs than
you can ever have in a magazine spread
where maybe you'd get two or three in a
detail and you could just havin a whole
parade of mangas of images you know I
think really help the reader understand
the experience you asked me about ten
questions in there that's like somebody
at a presidential press conference who
knows they're only going to get one shot
how do you get into it you know it's
very hard to say i think it's changing
so rapidly in a in a good way you know I
you know I'm at this guy who started
this you know website called artisans
and architects and every time I ever
since I gave him
my business card to my slight regret you
know I get about two of them a day but
you know he does a very nice thing
they're very nicely designed you know if
you know maybe he's going to catch on
somewhere and he's probably not making
many any money doing it but i do think
they're going to be more and more
outlets i think that your generation
particular is very interested in
architecture and design and you need to
be enterprising that's not a very good
answer but good luck to you if you if
you start a blog send it to me I want to
get some oh yes indeed since we have you
and professor Wiseman there I thought I
might ask you if you could articulate
about some of the differences perhaps in
process as well as purpose in
approaching writing a piece from a
reporting perspective as well as from an
academic or scholarly perspective cool
I think I actually think a lot of the
research and information and knowledge
that you need for or that's extremely
helpful in writing for the popular press
or the mainstream press or the general
reader is not too similar to what you
need to do to produce you know a
thoroughly research and well considered
academic piece the difference is in the
piece for the general reader you're
going to bury about ninety percent of
what you've learned because you can't I
find in unless you're writing something
unless you really have a lot of space
you really are giving a reader two or
three key ideas and a piece to construct
an argument for a particular project or
a particular theme and you want to be
very well informed and knowledgeable but
you are walking a very delicate line
with the general reader and assuming too
much knowledge but you have to find a
way to write it so they don't feel the
reader does not feel talked down to it's
kind of delicate and it's a little bit
hard to explain how one does it but I
both learn to do it and I've also edited
a lot of young writers writing call on
cultural subjects I sir I'm sort of
taught people how to do it but it's a
it's a very interesting process I do
think the one of the big differences
between scholarly writing and writing
for the popular presses is that scholars
are first of all engaged in a lot of
original historical research and they're
also engaged in the in a theoretical
world which really doesn't have a lot of
room in mainstream writing does that
help I think I think this touches on
something that I've been waiting for a
question about the the transition from
from print to digital and this there's
something going on there's a new website
out just recently about long-form
journalism cannabis okay and I thought
this is interesting yes
I we all get our news breaks our hot
architects hot buildings or whatever in
a format this size but it's now possible
to upend something at much greater
length if you if you want to get it so
you you actually could have the william
jordi addition if you like after the
after the news headlines and I think
that provides a real opportunity going
forward in in our understanding of
architecture because the information can
move quite rapidly but to the degree you
want to investigate it there's it's much
easier to do that well that's why I
think the ipad could save magazines or
something like it or its next-generation
because first of all the images are
beautiful and I never thought the images
were beautiful enough fun the internet
for visual covering visual culture of
any kind the images are gorgeous and
secondly you know it Linda it's portable
so you can start your long-form article
you know on the bus and bookmark it so
you come back and third it you can
because you can do anything on it you
can get as much depth of knowledge as
you want so you're interested in the
engineering maybe not everybody is you
can you know you can hit a link and go
to a website or you could go to a
sidebar I mean it gives the potential
for layering information videos
photography longer pieces so that any
reader can take a piece and kind of
tailor it to their own interests or time
at that moment is just fantastic and
something that you know obviously we
have any other magazines in print Tom
now your grades depend on this
I've been trying to sort of think of the
best way to put this I don't know if I
know it but as a critic well I mean
would you say you're a critic or a
journalist there's one question or both
know you could you make a distinction
between the two and in relation to that
what would you say are the fundamental
goals of your job in writing
architectural articles to be read by the
mainstream to what level is a criticism
education advocacy pacemaking that's a
good question uh all critic search
should be journalists not all
journalists or critics okay um I don't
think that those different categories
are I mean I think they all overlap I
mean I think I think education is really
the primary role is to educate the
reader with a set of important point
appoints enough background information
context detail and argument um you know
obviously persuasion is a big part of
criticism it's not necessarily a part of
every work of reporting I you know I
well I'll go back to the World Trade
Center but you know there were six
schemes for the final plan and and a lot
of people just described all six and
some of us described all six but clearly
indicated preferences among them so
that's sort of reporting / criticism and
then some people you know only went to
the mat for one scheme and you built an
enormous argument out of that I did not
do that but I did certainly you know
right about it was clear if you read it
you know where some problem where my
preference is lay
an interesting word came up in this
question of advocacy and you touched on
that earlier and I think it's an issue
in in in criticism and even in
scholarship that if if one is persuaded
that your discovery or your guy or your
gal needs to be advanced you will invest
in that but the great hazard I always
felt was if you get tagged as someone
who is in somebody's pocket your
credibility vanishes and and you only
get credibility once as a journalist you
really cannot put it back together and I
think we're we're in some of you in you
know in my classes we've discussed this
at what point does the enthusiasm of a
critic or a scholar for a particular
architect a particular movement begin to
move into advertising and at what point
do you begin to question that person's
opinion did have you have you been has
that come up in your own career well
I've been pretty Catholic in my taste
just I think anybody who has read me
since that I'm you know I certainly have
written very favorably about Gary and
I've also written very favorably about
much more minimalist architects I mean I
I don't feel that I am have a particular
taste or agenda that I am promoting but
I think advocacy is really important in
the way in another way which is when I
what I was talking about when I was
saying about my interest in cities and
urban design i mean i think architecture
critics can play a huge role in making
people see not just this building which
might be great but my god look at the
way it hits the street look at the way
it affects the neighborhood look at the
fact might be there no windows on the
ground floor look at you know i'm so
sick of seeing pictures of the
Gary skyscraper like it's just this icon
sticking up in the sky mean they're
people have to walk by it every day and
it is a pretty bland plain brick box at
the bottom and I'm not sure that was the
best choice and I see you see lots of
City pictures that are taken sort of
helicopter shots and I you know I find
them very offensive if there isn't also
in the layout something would show
street life so just showing that and
writing about it and getting people to
readers to consider that is I think a
very important aspect of criticism and
if you read certain writers you you will
see that they intend often tend to
advocate that kind of thing again and
again and while others completely
overlooked it I think we're closing in
on our appointed hour are there a couple
more questions for Kathleen before we we
adjourn this has been fascinating and
really moved over the spectrum that we
were hoping I think to cover of of
journalism and architecture and
criticism with a little other stuff
thrown in but um I want to know what um
pieces you regret oh you didn't go there
okay but that that's about me and I'm
not really well the first one I strongly
endorse the first gwathmey scheme for
the Guggenheim edition and I did that
for all the wrong reasons and and I'm
I'm proud to admit it partner it was it
was ugly and out of scale and stupid and
when ada louise huxtable dubbed it the
toilet tank edition no one could ever
look at it differently yeah I realized
that I had been caught way out on a limb
and my my argument behind doing it was
that I was annoyed that so many people
were complaining about an addition to a
great work of art and my feeling was
that no great work of architecture
should be immune
to addition or improvement if you can
find the architect who can improve it
and I was sticking up for the idea but
not looking very hard at what what was
proposed humble museum oh well that one
I didn't write about but I think that
was me buddy remember what they wanted
to clone it they wanted to keep adding
Bay's to both sides and there was a huge
huge room a lot of it took place in the
New York Times and a great public
meeting where were you at the meeting
where yeah I gitex really did it where
there were cons widow and both the
mistresses were all in the hall was just
that to me was the most fascinating part
I'm for Ted feels very oh he was
hammered he was never did enjoy he was
doing the right thing by appearing he
was the director of the museum anyway
they we did write about that in Newsweek
and there was there was a bit of a to
your coat your question about
scholarship the one that there was
nishio scholarship here which was what
were cons intentions and what had he
left and there was some conflict in the
scholarship too so I covered that a
little bit too but I was very gratified
not to end oh this is gonna sound a
little self aggrandizing but I was very
gratified that I learned later from Sue
Ann con that the board of the I in the
piece one of the things common had said
was if you ever want to add to it you
should build across the lawn and
apparently the board of the Museum in
Fort Worth they didn't care what a bunch
of new york architects in New York Times
said they didn't hear about that but
Newsweek then it was that I think the
only time i felt i had a little a little
kind of hef just because of my forum
that kind of embarrassed them according
to sue ann khan and the project to add
the base was dropped and now renzo piano
is building across the
well we thank you for your participation
saving that